let's see if we can get an idea of
what's going on inside president putin's
ahead mikhail khasnov
was a prime minister of russia from 2000
to 2004 during president putin's first
administration he's now with the
opposition people's freedom party in
russia welcome to dw sir you know the
president well what do you think the
purpose of this invasion is
thank you for having me in the program
uh i think that's uh it's completely
different putin uh in fact before monday
i believed and i thought that mr putin
was bluffing bluffing trying to get
concessions from the west on just
those uh i would say imagine security
threats etc for a few months those
negotiations and he
wanted to have pictures just shaking
hands of
president biden and other european
leaders and
on monday when i watched tv and mr
putin's speech on the
meeting of the security council and
later his strange lecture with the full
contradictions and imagine the history
stories i understood that something
wrong with the
i think just mr putin
is out of a normal mind and in fact what
is happening today it's it's absolutely
disaster as a disaster that is
i would say
violation of international law just no
one could expect such a violation no
such a disaster right
the fear before this happened was that
if it happened
mr putin would not stop at donetsk and
luhansk and would go for the whole of
the country now the fear must be that
perhaps he won't even stop at ukraine
uh right now you're correct
it's absolutely unpredictable situation
nobody can predict what mr putin thinks
right now and what his ambition is at
the moment in fact you know just there
is there is uh such kind of that
explanation that
he wants to restore so-called nova
russia which is um
a couple of centuries ago from donbass
to odessa
so that uh and ukraine has no access to
black to the black sea that is maybe
this is the idea at the moment that we
see and herself which is uh
other part
thousand part of uh of ukraine uh
russian tanks are there and people
already complaining that they didn't
expect just that so quickly those things
would appear it means mr putin going
further on to address and transnistria
this very dangerous development taking
place right now
without 2020 hindsight what do you think
could this have been prevented if uh the
west the eu the nato the u.s had taken
tougher action uh previously
uh uh previously uh i i don't i don't
think that would prevent because mr
putin just
explained
that they're prepared in fact you can
imagine that mr putin and his inner
circle they are prepared to live in
isolation
they they all came from the soviet union
and as many of us and they were in kgb
and kgb was an elite organization and
they lived in a very well conditions and
right now they believe they will survive
uh the same way they don't care about
russian people and and and just the
whole situation in russia they're
thinking about themselves they're
prepared for isolation but i don't think
they realized how difficult that would
be if those hush sanctions which were
explained previously by uh american
european leaders would be exposed that
will be disaster for economy and if
foreign exchange inflow would stop
coming into russia it means just
dramatic devaluation of ruble it means
absolutely uh growing poverty every day
it means growing negative attitude to mr
putin within short period of time
all right well let's pick up that point
then let's hear uh from the uh president
of the european commission ursula fonda
line talking about sanctions
let me be very clear
it is president putin who will have to
explain this to his citizens
i know
that the russian people do not want this
war
the european union and nato have worked
in close complementarity
and this crisis will bring us even
closer together
it is our shared duty to stand up to the
gravest act of aggression on european
soil since decades
mikhail cassian offer you and uh fond du
land uh both made at the same point that
this will lead to unrest amongst the
russian people but we have a russian
president who has been in power
long enough that he knows which levers
to pull and he can keep his people down
so this isolation that you you talk
about that you think that you say that
will not bother him but will bother the
russian people will will he be bothered
by their response
people would understand that they
already have nothing to lose uh ordinary
people which is more than 50 percent of
population uh which live in very poor
conditions and you know just the poverty
is 20 million people just people who
live under the level
appropriate level of living and that
these people would start would start
understanding that
we'll start to understand what's going
on why just russia such a rich country
and having such a big problems and they
cannot they cannot survive middle class
and the big cities already started to to
to protest and some people already put
an arrest were arrested and put and put
in jail just during the day that we
already see reports from moscow and
saint petersburg for example and i think
that that will be growing growing unrest
of people not immediately but uh during
a short period of time with absolutely
mature mature a clear vision who is
responsible who for for all those
problems who is guilty
where the source of all danger for
russian people is i think they will
clearly would understand and without
help of my
party people's freedom party although we
are under pressure right now and we
cease to exist this year because just uh
government already just announced that
we should call be close very soon
because we in cooperation with so-called
undesirable organization abroad it means
uh our
parties
in european union just with whom they
cooperate very closely because we have
common values and we will be closed very
soon we already made those statements of
course this morning and yesterday
and and we uh realized just how
difficult for people would be to accept
what is going on and how difficult it
would be to overcome when the sanctions
would be exposed so just
okay no we've got that let me just bust
in there and just just talk about this
this process because this
looks like it's
going to be a very long drawn out
process you have the invasion which has
now started you have international
leaders talking about sanctions they
have then to agree them and the eu is is
not quick to do that
as an example they have to agree them
they have to implement them then they
have to bite
during which time uh russia becomes more
and more embedded in whichever bits of
ukraine or indeed the whole country it
has taken so we are talking about months
in this process before we see sanctions
actually working aren't we
uh it's not a question for me i think
just because
european leaders should decide just
how how fast and how harsh how how
strong those sanctions should be what
other response is because there is no
any instrument in their hands but in
fact if if now i can say i can tell you
that if the sanctions will touch early
and guest sector that will be immediate
effect within a couple of months because
just um you know the
uh for for foreign exchange will not
come to russia and that means it will be
a huge pressure to ruble it means just
the variation of national currency it
means just no access for international
foreign markets
it means just russian banking system
cannot cannot finance anything it means
printing money it means
hyperinflation it means disaster and
unrest on the streets
so that's a response to russia what
about a response for ukraine is there
anything more that the west could be
doing uh for ukraine
uh i think the rest should reconsider
all what's going what's going on and is
going going around ukraine since 2014
and
the
the west should
recall that there is so-called budapest
memorandum where
united states and great britain promised
to ukraine to
protect and to respect into the
territorial integrity and sovereignty of
the country uh a part of those economic
sanctions i think just there is a global
security threat
and uh
i think i think just violation of
international law violation of all those
agreements in in budapest memorandum in
particular is a serious issue i think uh
ukrainian government already called
members of budapest memorandum to to to
set up a special discussion and and
think about this how to tackle this
threat which appeared just yesterday
understood thank you and very clear sir
thank you for joining us former uh prime
minister of russia mikhail kassianov
thank you
vladimir putin announced this invasion
as u.n secretary general antonio
guterres was speaking at an emergency
session of the u.n security council and
urging the russian president to give
peace a chance mr putin's televised
late-night address came shortly after
self-proclaimed separatist leaders in
eastern ukraine asked him for military
support this attack is the culmination
of a series of escalations that began on
monday when president putin recognized
the independence of two regions in
eastern ukraine including territory
controlled by kiev
i'm addressing the ukrainian army please
lay down your arms
your grandads and your great
grandfathers did not fight the nazis and
defend our common fatherland so that
neo-nazis would seize power in ukraine
you made an oath to serve the ukrainian
people
they are a fascist hunter who have
seized power
they're plundering ukraine and
exploiting its people don't fulfill
their criminal orders
lay down your weapons and go home
let me take you back to ukraine now
we'll speak to andrea yesker who's a
journalist she's in the don bass region
in ukraine's east she joins us on the
line from pokhlovsk in donetsk uh
welcome to dw andrea
explain to us geographically where you
are and what's what you can see what's
been happening
yeah we are in for crosstalk now we left
the industrial town of yavka this
morning we came to optivga about three
days ago and the situation was quite
calm
astonishingly come because we talked to
a lot of people there and asking them
what they expect and everybody said oh
they are expecting nothing um they did
not expect to be invaded and they were
so calm saying you know we've had
violence here and challenged for eight
years so this situation is not any
different for us
yesterday just yesterday we went to the
hospital to ask if they are taking any
preparation for the worst case and they
said no there was nothing no blood no
transfusion no
just just nothing no food no water in
the cellar
and then
also last night we talked to people and
they said no no everything has come
everything is okay and this morning the
town woke up to the wall and people
started going to work started walking
their dogs and they were quite calm but
during the day everything started
deteriorating
it became very
very extreme the the shellings came very
close there was artillery fire within
the outskirts of the city already
and
the people are expecting that the
russian army will take the city today
tomorrow but in the very very near
future
and people started panicking later on
and then started to leave packing their
cars and that was that was quite
surprising because in the morning
everybody had still told us no no we are
not going everything will be fine and
then in the afternoon it seems like it
was was trickling into the minds of the
people that this is a dangerous
situation
and where are they going do you know
yeah well one man said he would go to
prague because he has a son then there
were a few people who said they want to
go to kiev and then others were
contradicting them and said no don't go
to kiev we heard it's under fire already
so they were saying yeah but what should
we do we don't have any other place to
go or our children are there and the the
problem for many people is that this
region has been so poor throughout all
the years and um that people do not have
the money to move out and live somewhere
else because apartments anywhere else
are much too expensive for them
and
what we also heard from a lot of people
was that they are really really glad
that the russian army is coming a lot of
them said well then finally it's going
to be over because we've lived with
violence for such a long time it was so
terrible and then there was a lot of
disappointment in the eu and the west
and the american politics saying you
left us alone you said this is a frozen
conflict but it was a it was a war all
along you you caught the contact line
but it was a front line and we were
dying and we are poor and why should we
be with you we are very happy that putin
is coming and finally liberating us
there were a couple of the i i'd like to
explore that idea that you you mentioned
that of relief so because on on the one
hand you seem to be saying that the
people were relieved to see the russians
and other people believe that well at
least we have an end to all the
uncertainty
yes that's true i think this this end is
very important even for people who are
not pro-russia or pro-separatists
the people are just so tired we have
been in ukraine last year around this
time a little later and we talked to
them then and and
already then they said we are so tired
we we do not know how to live under
these circumstances anymore and you must
imagine there are families raising their
kids for eight years now directly on the
front line in these villages families
who are too poor to leave the village
and
and
the mothers are
have a bad conscience because they think
they are not protecting their children
properly the children go to the school
bus and you never know whether they come
back because they have the mortars and
everything and artillery all the time
and children got killed and they got hit
and you have the snipers somewhere you
have to cross the street in the village
from one side to another to visit your
neighbor but you are right in the in the
view of the sniper there and you never
know if he is in a bad mood that day or
decides that he's gonna kill you and
that was terrible for the people
and this has all been going on in the in
the last year before we reached this
this this terrible climax you also
talked there about that their sense of
disappointment in the reactions from the
from the west from the united states
excuse me from the united states and
from the european union
yeah well it's it's not the reaction now
it's direction throughout all these
eight years that have passed since 2014
because after that they have the feeling
nobody was interested in the conflict in
ukraine anymore europe and the americans
declared it as somehow solved through
the minsk treaty but for the people it
was not solved and they said yeah you
didn't look at this throughout all these
years where were you now
you you come and you get all hysteric
about it all but this was our life all
these years and then you never noticed
it and you didn't come to help us this
is what they say and they do understand
their point i mean if i lived there
maybe i would would also see it like
that
that sounds desperate we thank you for
joining us and just painting that
picture for us andrea yes who's
reporting from the donbass region in
ukraine's easter thank you for joining
dw
bye